[Música]
bienvenidos y bienvenidas al espacio de
cultura de france 24 después de tres
semanas del inicio de la guerra en
ucrania proteger los monumentos y los
museos sigue siendo una urgencia en un
desa se teme que el patrimonio cultural
pueda quedar destruido como ya sucedió
en ciudades como mariupol o hardcore y
por eso las autoridades piden una zona
de exclusión áerea aprendemos más sobre
esta situación con el reportaje de
nuestros enviados especiales
catalina gómez ángel y oriol andrés
gallardo
las barricadas construidas con
neumáticos y erizos de acero han pasado
a ser parte del paisaje del centro
histórico de odessa enmarcado por el
edificio del teatro de la ópera y el
ballet reconstruido en 1887 por los
arquitectos austriacos ferdinand feller
y hernán gelver la responsable de
relaciones públicas del teatro luzmila
sergi llull y el cantante anato lapas to
hope han pasado algunos de los momentos
más importantes de su vida en este
edificio al que hoy se prohibió el
acceso tal como sucede con gran parte de
los monumentos de la ciudad se ser según
desee si el juego ni paul y este es el
corazón de odessa no pasa nada
importante en esta ciudad que no incluye
al teatro nosotros lo amamos desde lo
más profundo de nuestro corazón solía
ser
nuestra misión principal es protegerlo
cueste lo que cueste porque podemos
esperar cualquier cosa de putin hemos
dos de estos robots
la memoria de la segunda guerra mundial
cuando la población dio de esa se
movilizó para salvar su patrimonio
cultural y las obras de arte ha vuelto a
revivirse en las últimas semanas
especialmente en el museo nacional que
guarda obras maestras de la cultura
ucraniana como también rusa
paradójico y duro para mí es darme
cuenta que los museos ucranianos están
intentando salvar las obras de artes
rusas de la invasión rusa
giuliana lidera sus 83 años la
protección de la biblioteca regional de
odessa fundada en 1875
daños por la bomba nunca entrará a este
lugar mire hemos traído todo aquí
más de un millón de libros han sido
trasladados a este sótano y algunos de
los títulos más importantes han sido
escaneados para salvarnos de una
eventual destrucción
tenemos muchos libros que son del
comienzo del siglo 18 y hacemos un gran
esfuerzo para protegerlos
este es patrimonio de la literatura
ucraniana que puede ser más valioso que
la culture news cultura la ciudad de
odessa se ha movilizado en las últimas
tres semanas para salvar el patrimonio
cultural temen que se dé un ataque por
ejemplo el como el que se dio al teatro
de la ciudad de mariupol sin embargo hay
una esperanza de que pueda abrirse una
ventana para salvarlas y que haya una
negociación de paz antes de que la
ciudad sea atacada frente a la violencia
de una guerra los eventos culturales de
la vida cotidiana como los festivales de
cine o de series podrían parecer
inútiles pero tienen su importancia es
lo que julia sincovich contó a france 24
cofundadora de la academia de cine de
ucrania y durante una década responsable
de uno de los festivales de cine con
mayor audiencia de europa el festival
internacional de odessa la productora
está ahora en el river pero espera ir a
francia para el festival series man ya
cuyo jurado dirige una nominación
obviamente muy simbólica que ya aceptó
inmediatamente la escuchamos
yo como persona de cultura creo que este
es el idioma que mejor puedo hablar
necesidad
[Música]
y sí creo que la cultura es de hecho una
herramienta poderosa para detener la
agresión para mostrar al mundo que las
vidas son lo más importante y para
contar historias que toquen el corazón
de la gente no de los políticos no de
las cifras los números las estadísticas
sino de las almas humanas numbers chiste
expats human shows la necesidad de
seguir produciendo arte a pesar de todo
es algo que los ucranianos comparten con
todos los artistas que trabajan en
territorios difíciles la ciudad de
trípoli en el norte de líbano es un
ejemplo perfecto conocida por su
aplastante pobreza y extremismo pero
donde un pequeñito equipo está
restaurando la histórica sala de cine
empire que lleva más de dos décadas
abandonada el objetivo de mostrar que
trípoli es una ciudad de cultura y que
cuando se abre un lugar artístico la
gente asiste es que dentro de seis meses
podamos abrirlo y establecer el primer
festival de cine en trípoli y organizar
un festival entre el sur y el norte para
decir que estamos más allá de la
centralización cultural la cultura y el
arte no deben ser monopolizados por las
capitales ni por una clase social o un
grupo específico el arte es para todos
alirio mirar el arte es para todos un
mantra que impulsa a artistas de todos
los continentes y que mejor manera que
sacar la cultura a la calle para hacerla
más accesible en yamena por ejemplo la
capital del chad hace varios años que el
actor ve un avance inmediato bonga
organiza lecturas de teatro para llevar
la cultura a los barrios populares
si quiere ver el perfil
mientras que en venezuela en el humilde
barrio de petare las fiestas móviles
reúnen personas alrededor de la música y
del baile
[Música]
y para despedirnos nos quedamos en las
calles donde artistas de francia kosovo
y argentina entre otros
rindieron homenaje al pueblo ucraniano
gracias por su confianza y cuídense
[Música]
e
y
i